we have to cue ourselves and we don't
realize that we are constantly curing
ourselves i love it when people say oh
take a deep breath or pause for a second
secretly that also makes us sound better
so here's a couple things that you can
think about to actually cue yourself for
confidence the first one is i want you
to maximize the distance between your
earlobe and your shoulder what i often
see on video is people hike up their
shoulders and they tilt down their head
and they go hey
and they do that because when we're a
little nervous a little anxious we try
to take up as little space as possible
so we do that instinctively and what can
happen is we're getting ready for a
meeting or a video call and what are we
doing checking our email literally
checking our email or checking our phone
is the exact position of the feet by
accident right
our our shoulders are tucked our chin is
tucked our arms are to our side we're
blocking
and some people wonder why they're
making bad first impressions or why they
feel so awkward at the start of video
calls because accidentally
like this and then hello and they pop up
and brought and broadened